Générique
...
- Alexandre Poussart:
Bonjour à tous.
Heureux de vous retrouver
pour "Parlement hebdo".
- Kathia Gilder: Notre invité est
Julien Bayou.
Bonjour.
- Julien Bayou: Bonjour.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous êtes député
écologiste de Paris.
On a beaucoup d'actualité pour
vous.
- Alexandre Poussart: Les
violences urbaines monopolisent
les débats au Parlement.
Le gouvernement estime avoir
rétabli l'ordre républicain alors
que la gauche demande des réponses
sociales et la droite exige des
mesures sécuritaires.
La ministre Marlène Schiappa dans
le viseur du Sénat.
On l'accuse d'avoir porté une
responsabilité politique dans la
mauvaise gestion de ce fonds
gouvernemental censé être dirigé
contre la radicalisation en ligne,
mais qui a été mal utilisé.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'Assemblée
nationale, la séance des questions
au gouvernement était très
attendue après une semaine de
violences et de pillages.
Quasiment l'intégralité des
questions ont porté sur les
émeutes.
- Pendant deux heures, Elisabeth
Borne est sur le gril.
Presque toutes les questions au
gouvernement portent sur les
émeutes.
- Comment un jeune de 17 ans
peut-il être tué par un policier
en République française?
Pourquoi 16 personnes ont-elles
trouvé la mort depuis un an et
demi en France pour un refus
d'obtempérer quand l'Allemagne ne
compte qu'un mort en 10 ans?
- Vous cherchez des coupables dans
toutes nos institutions
républicaines, sauf chez les
auteurs de violences.
Madame la présidente Mathilde
Panot, quand vos députés rejettent
les appels au calme, vous sortez
du champ républicain.
- La Première ministre accuse les
insoumis d'instrumentaliser la
mort de Nahel.
Les Républicains appellent à
sanctionner les parents des
émeutiers.
- Quand on laisse un gamin de 15
ans dehors à 2h du matin par une
nuit d'émeutes, on doit voir sa
responsabilité engagée.
- Pour le Rassemblement National,
Marine Le Pen dénonce le chaos
sécuritaire.
- Qu'avez-vous fait de la France?
Vous menez la même politique que
vos prédécesseurs depuis 40 ans.
Vous vous préparez à nous
resservir un énième plan
Banlieues.
Je vous appelle au courage de
l'autocritique.
Il faut stopper l'immigration
anarchique.
- Vous démontrez encore que la
seule chose dont vous êtes
capable, c'est la caricature.
Ca ne me surprend pas, mais je
regrette que le choix que vous
faites soit celui de la division.
- L'Assemblée va continuer de se
pencher sur ces violences
urbaines.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que pour
vous, l'exécutif a bien géré cette
crise?
- Julien Bayou: A revoir votre
reportage, j'ai l'impression que
ni l'exécutif ni le législatif, et
je m'inclus dedans, n'ont bien
géré cette crise.
On verse dans la caricature et la
schématisation.
Je me suis peu exprimé jusqu'ici.
J'ai beaucoup lu, j'ai discuté
avec des maires sur le terrain.
Une personne qui dit qu'il n'y a
qu'une seule réponse sans nuance à
cette question fait du tort aux
débats.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous avez donc
préféré prendre du recul plutôt
que d'avoir des déclarations que
vous pourriez regretter?
- Julien Bayou: Ca peut arriver.
L'émotion était forte.
Qui n'a pas pu être ému face à ce
crime, cet homicide, cet
assassinat?
Le policier devra répondre de ses
actes.
Qui n'a pas été en colère devant
ces pillages injustifiables?
Dire que c'était soit l'un soit
l'autre, qu'il y aurait forcément
un camp auquel il faudrait se
rattacher...
La réalité est infiniment plus
nuancée.
Vous avez des personnes dans les
quartiers populaires qui pleurent
leurs services publics, qui n'ont
plus de bus ou de voiture pour
aller travailler.
Cela m'inquiète, en réalité.
Si on ne prend pas un temps de
réflexion, si on ne prend pas
cette énième alerte au sérieux,
alors le pays se désagrège.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va
évoquer les réponses à apporter à
cette crise, mais d'abord, une
réponse politique.
Les insoumis n'ont pas appelé au
calme dès le début de ces émeutes.
Est-ce que c'est une faute?
- Julien Bayou: Je ne veux pas
entrer dans la polémique
permanente.
La justice exige du temps.
J'ai vu beaucoup d'interviews de
maires qui rendaient compte de la
situation, et on leur demandait de
se positionner par rapport à untel
ou untel.
Pendant ce temps, la question,
c'était: comment faire en sorte
que la mairie ne soit pas brûlée
le lendemain?
Les jeunes professeurs, qui sont
peu formés,
finissent désespérés.
Quand ils commencent dans les
classes difficiles, ils finissent
par s'en aller.
Si la polémique empêche de poser
les questions auxquelles il faut
répondre, c'est un problème.
Il y a eu 13 morts l'an dernier
suite à un refus d'obtempérer.
Combien n'ont pas été filmées?
Si aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'Intérieur ne nous dit pas cela,
il y a un problème.
- Kathia Gilder: Le fait qu'il y
ait eu une vidéo, ça change la
donne.
On voit bien l'impact de cette
vidéo diffusée et relayée
massivement.
- Julien Bayou: Tout le monde
ressent le choc de la vidéo.
Tout le monde mesure bien que l'on
n'est pas égal face à un contrôle
policier.
Ca ne dégénère pas forcément
suivant les quartiers et selon le
niveau d'expérience des policiers.
Quand on a réduit la durée de
formation des policiers, on ne
leur a pas rendu service.
On déplore la perte de la police
de proximité.
Si les gouvernements successifs ne
veulent pas la remettre, changeons
le nom.
On a besoin d'une police au
contact des quartiers.
Il y a un non-dit.
Je profite du fait que l'on ait un
peu de temps.
Le trafic de stupéfiants empêche
la police de proximité, empêche
même les pompiers d'intervenir,
parfois.
A quand la légalisation?
Quand est-ce que l'on mesurera
enfin que non seulement cela crée
des problèmes de sécurité, mais
aussi de santé publique?
- Alexandre Poussart: La
légalisation du cannabis?
- Julien Bayou: On a une des
politiques les plus répressives.
Il faut un vrai débat.
Je ne veux pas arriver à des
solutions toutes faites.
Il faut poser sérieusement le
débat d'une et du taux d'addiction
chez les mineurs le plus élevé.
- Alexandre Poussart: Pour vous,
la légalisation du cannabis peut
être une solution pour rétablir le
calme dans les banlieues?
- Julien Bayou: Ce n'est
certainement pas la seule.
- Kathia Gilder: Cela peut mettre
fin à des trafics qui sont
installés dans des cités où les
policiers ne peuvent plus aller.
- Julien Bayou: Il y a la question
de la santé publique.
Le cannabis est dangereux, pour
les adolescents en particulier.
Il y a un phénomène d'addiction
indubitable.
La prohibition est un échec.
Cela a plein d'effets négatifs
corollaires sur la sécurité et
même sur la population carcérale.
Je relisais il n'y a pas longtemps
l'appel de Grigny.
Ce sont des maires de banlieue qui
affirmaient qu'on leur enlevait
les emplois aidés.
C'était les soutiens scolaires,
les appuis aux associations...
Cela fait plusieurs années qu'ils
ont disparu.
Est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train
d'en payer le prix?
- Alexandre Poussart: On va
évoquer le profil des émeutiers,
très jeunes.
Gérald Darmanin a été auditionné
au Sénat cette semaine et en a
parlé.
- La sociologie des délinquants et
des émeutiers interroge.
Sur les 3500 interpellations, la
moyenne d'âge est entre 17 et 18
ans.
A ma connaissance, 60% des
personnes interpellées n'ont pas
de casier judiciaire et ne sont
pas connus des services de police.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
la solution à ce profil
sociologique, des émeutiers très
jeunes, c'est d'abord de rétablir
l'autorité parentale?
Emmanuel Macron réfléchit à
sanctionner financièrement les
parents des émeutiers.
- Julien Bayou: Cela relève du
slogan.
J'évoquais l'appel de Grigny,
resté lettre morte.
On se posait la question des
familles monoparentales.
Les mères isolées après un
divorce, une séparation, qui se
retrouvent, en général, avec la
garde des enfants.
Pour vivre avec un loyer qui
augmente, avec des dépenses de
santé et de nourriture, elles
doivent travailler.
Les femmes sont plus souvent
victimes de travail précaire, de
travail à temps partiel contraint.
Dans ces situations, cela veut
dire quoi, sanctionner une mère
isolée qui travaille le soir ou la
nuit avec parfois des trajets de
transport très longs parce qu'elle
n'a pas pu payer quelqu'un pour
surveiller l'enfant?
Je veux bien, les slogans, mais
personne n'y croit.
Cela veut dire que parce que une
mère n'a pas pu payer de nounou ou
quelqu'un qui garde l'enfant à la
maison, on va lui mettre la tête
sous l'eau encore plus?
Il faut l'accompagner.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous dites que la
répression n'est pas la bonne
réponse.
Comment vous empêchez un jeune de
sortir la nuit avec des cocktail
Molotov pour aller attaquer des
écoles?
Quelle est la bonne réponse?
- Julien Bayou: La personne qui
vient avec une seule réponse,
comme je l'ai dit, se trompe.
Le plan Borloo...
L'appel de Grigny a débouché sur
le plan Borloo, qui a été rejeté
par le gouvernement.
Ce plan prévoyait notamment des
adultes relais.
Il y avait la multiplication des
services publics au coeur des
îlots.
Il y avait la multiplication des
mamans de la République, d'une
formation pour les mères isolées
et autres.
Une réponse très globale qui
n'excluait pas de sanctionner
quand il y avait un dérapage.
Il y avait une réponse beaucoup
plus globale.
On peut aussi s'interroger sur les
phénomènes d'émulation entre
jeunes garçons.
On a vu peu de filles.
Ces jeunes garçons, sous l'effet
du phénomène de bande, se sont
monté la tête.
Cela doit interroger.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il faut donc
regarder toutes les mesures
proposées par le plan Borloo.
- Julien Bayou: Oui.
- Kathia Gilder: Dans ce contexte
bouillant, une loi de
programmation est examinée à
l'Assemblée nationale pour donner
plus de moyens à la justice.
10.000 postes supplémentaires
d'ici 2027.
Explications avec Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- C'est une des réformes de la
magistrature les plus ambitieuses
de l'histoire de la Ve République.
Comme je vous l'avais dit, je suis
venu avec vous tourner la page des
mauvaises habitudes qui gangrènent
notre justice depuis de trop
nombreuses années.
L'un des objectifs est clair,
ambitieux: diviser par deux
l'ensemble du délai de justice
d'ici 2027.
- Kathia Gilder: Le gouvernement
veut donc améliorer fortement les
moyens de la justice.
Est-ce que c'est nécessaire?
- Julien Bayou: C'est crucial.
Si vous n'avez pas accès à la
justice, vous n'êtes pas
véritablement un citoyen.
Avoir accès à la justice, c'est
pouvoir faire valoir son droit.
Que l'on ait gain de cause ou non,
la possibilité d'accéder à la
justice est cruciale.
Cela fait partie des sujets
majeurs dont on parlait juste
avant.
Lorsqu'on est dans les quartiers
sensibles, l'accès aux services
publics, dont la justice, est
fortement entravé.
C'est l'ensemble des politiques
qui, dans ces quartiers, sont en
recul: santé, éducation,
justice...
S'il y a beaucoup de points de
désaccord, parce que ce n'est pas
qu'un projet de budget pour la
justice, le fait de pouvoir
rattraper
notre retard colossal en matière
de juge par habitant est le
bienvenu.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il y a une
mesure de ce texte qui fait
polémique.
Elle permet d'activer à distance
des téléphones pour surveiller
certains suspects dans certaines
enquêtes, notamment sur le crime
organisé ou les affaires de
terrorisme.
- Julien Bayou: C'est une atteinte
aux libertés.
Sans esprit de polémique, la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
sanctionné la Russie parce qu'elle
avait activé la reconnaissance
faciale pour identifier un
manifestant pacifique.
Elle l'a retrouvé dans le métro.
Je ne suis pas en train de dire
que la France et la Russie...
Je dis que nous sommes en train de
valider cela à l'occasion du
projet de loi pour les JO.
Nous sommes en train de valider
des outils foncièrement
problématiques.
Si c'est utilisé par un
gouvernement qui vous plaît, tout
va bien.
Si c'est utilisé par un
gouvernement qui ne vous plaît
pas, il y a un problème.
Nous banalisons certaines
procédures, comme l'état
d'urgence.
Cela m'inquiète.
La liberté de manifestation est en
recul.
Les manifestations du 1er mai, par
exemple, ne sont plus aussi
familiales qu'il y a 15 ans.
Ce n'est pas que de la faute des
manifestants.
La liberté d'association recule.
On a des dissolutions à
répétition.
Il faut s'inquiéter du fait que la
liberté d'association recule.
La lutte contre la corruption
recule également.
- Alexandre Poussart: Direction le
Sénat, puisque la commission
d'enquête sur le fonds Marianne a
rendu ses conclusions.
Elle dénonce la responsabilité
politique de Marlène Schiappa.
- "Opération de communication",
"coup politique", les mots sont
durs.
- Le manque de rigueur, l'opacité
et la désinvolture ont conduit au
fiasco.
- Adopté à la quasi-unanimité, ce
rapport est accablant pour Marlène
Schiappa.
En avril dernier, six mois après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty, celle
qui était alors ministre chargée
de la Citoyenneté a lancé un fonds
pour lutter contre les discours
séparatistes.
2,5 millions d'euros ont été
attribués à 17 associations.
Comment ont-elles été choisies?
La commission d'enquête dénonce
l'amateurisme d'un processus de
sélection opaque, où la ministre
serait personnellement intervenue
sans laisser aucune trace écrite
justifiant ses choix.
SOS racisme, initialement
sélectionné, a finalement été
écarté.
- Dans le cas de SOS Racisme, la
ministre est intervenue pour
revenir sur une décision du comité
de sélection.
Un mail indique que la décision
d'exclure cette association a bien
été prise lors d'une réunion avec
la ministre.
- Les sénateurs reprochent aussi à
Marlène Schiappa d'avoir
sélectionné une association avant
même la création du fonds.
Pour 355.000 euros, cette
association, codirigée par Mohamed
Sifaoui, n'aurait produit que
quelques vidéos en ligne sans que
personne ne s'en émeuve.
- Les échecs du fonds Marianne
sont tout autant le résultat des
investissements, du manque
d'intérêt ou du désintérêt du
pouvoir politique après la
sélection des projets.
Est-ce un déni de responsabilité?
Après son lancement, à l'exception
d'une réunion de décembre 2021, on
ne peut distinguer aucun signe
d'une véritable implication
politique quant à la mise en
oeuvre de ce fonds Marianne.
La promesse qui avait été faite
solennellement devant les Français
à la suite d'un événement tragique
n'a pas été tenue.
Cela relève pleinement de la
responsabilité politique de la
ministre.
- Lors de son audition devant les
sénateurs, Marlène Schiappa a nié
toute implication personnelle.
Un témoignage contradictoire avec
celui d'autres acteurs entendus.
La commission d'enquête a
communiqué ses conclusions au
parquet national financier, qui a
déjà ouvert une information
judiciaire sur le sujet.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Sénat
dénonce la responsabilité
politique de Marlène Schiappa.
Est-ce qu'elle peut actuellement
encore rester ministre chargée des
associations?
- Julien Bayou: Je ne sais pas
comment vous le dire.
Elle est complètement
décrédibilisée.
Les petits coups de communication
politique, on en a vu beaucoup.
On peut même en être blasés.
Là, on parle de
l'instrumentalisation du pire
drame que l'on ait vu récemment,
l'assassinat terroriste de Samuel
Paty.
Qu'est-ce que c'est moche!
C'est l'ensemble du gouvernement
qui est déshonoré, si elle
continue.
J'ai un sentiment de dégoût.
Pendant ce temps, qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait contre la radicalisation?
Tout inquiète dans ce domaine.
Comment a-t-elle pu continuer sous
l'autorité de son ministre de
tutelle, de la Première ministre
et du président?
- Kathia Gilder: Vous diriez
qu'elle a effectivement privilégié
certaines associations?
- Julien Bayou: Même si ça ne vous
plaît pas, qui peut nier qu'ils
agissent contre les
discriminations?
- Kathia Gilder: Vous auriez
quelle vision de cela?
- Julien Bayou: J'espère qu'il y
aura des suites judiciaires.
Alexandre Poussart: Contre Marlène
Schiappa?
- Julien Bayou: Contre Marlène
Schiappa, contre les personnes qui
ont récupéré de l'argent public.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est une faute
politique?
- Julien Bayou: Oui.
On parlait des émeutiers en
comparution immédiate qui ont pris
plusieurs mois ferme avec mandat
de dépôt pour un pillage que je
condamne.
C'est un deux poids, deux mesures
terrible.
De la prison ferme pour des très
jeunes personnes sans casier et
là, on parle de possibles
détournements d'argent public, et
même pire.
Si la ministre des Associations au
gouvernement lance un plan contre
la déradicalisation pour servir
les copains, c'est infiniment
pire.
Ca risque pourtant d'être moins
condamné.
Il y a un devoir d'exemplarité.
- Kathia Gilder: On va jeter un
petit coup d'oeil à l'agenda à
venir au Parlement, avant de nous
quitter.
- Alexandre Poussart: Lundi, les
sénateurs vont examiner le projet
de loi pour le plein emploi.
Ce texte prévoit de conditionner
le versement du RSA à une
quinzaine d'heures d'activité ou
de formation par semaine.
Mercredi, la mission d'information
du Sénat sur la gestion durable de
la loi va rendre son rapport et
ses conclusions pour mieux
préserver la ressource en eau face
aux épisodes de sécheresse
récurrents.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'Assemblée
nationale, Gérald Darmanin sera
auditionné devant la commission
des lois et devant la commission
d'enquête sur les groupuscules.
La loi de programmation militaire
sera aussi à l'agenda mercredi.
On verra s'il y aura un accord
entre députés et sénateurs sur un
texte commun.
Julien Bayou, vous siégez au sein
de la commission de la défense.
Une partie des députés vont se
réunir avec les sénateurs pour
tenter de trouver un accord.
- Julien Bayou: Je fais partie de
cette commission mixte paritaire.
Nous sommes assez surpris que la
droite joue la course à l'échalote
avec le gouvernement.
- Kathia Gilder: Les sénateurs LR
ne sont pas d'accord avec le texte
actuellement rédigé.
Ils ne contestent pas les 413
milliards d'euros prévus par la
loi, mais ils contestent le
calendrier.
- Julien Bayou: C'est un peu
hypocrite.
On les a sentis très alignés, et
finalement, ils essayent de faire
échouer la commission mixte
paritaire avant les sénatoriales.
Cette loi de programmation
militaire nous engage pour des
décennies.
Décider d'un nouveau porte-avions
ou de solidarité européenne dans
l'armement ou la sécurité, ce ne
sont pas des choix qui doivent
être faits au hasard.
Si nous pouvons renforcer la
sécurité européenne commune, je
m'en réjouis.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce sera le mot de
la fin, Julien Bayou.
Merci d'avoir été le dernier
invité de cette saison.
On se retrouve à la rentrée.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis cette année.
Merci à toutes les équipes.